haven't spoken to Michael Jordan for 10  years because of something that you said  on air it's a really unfortunate  situation for me and him I said Michael  got to surround himself with better  people I didn't think he had a good  enough support and cast around him in  the front office and he took offense  and he called me and it wasn't a  pleasant conversation and we haven't  spoken since then did you know after  that phone call y'all likely wouldn't  talk for a while I thought it would blow  over to be honest with you he's stubborn  and I'm stubborn  and that's it if you had the opportunity  to talk to Michael now what is it that  you would you would say to mend that uh  I probably would say Hey you know  what I said was I believed  I'm sorry you took offense to it  and let's get past this bush and go back  to playing golf and having fun